The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right, so
let's go ahead and proceed
with vehicle scheduling.
What we try to do in
vehicle scheduling,
and that's up to this
point, we have frequently
determined for different
routes, identify
to deliver the service that
this specified on the timetable.
And then vehicle scheduling,
which is the main part,
is basically how we are
using the existing fleet
to deliver the service that is
specified on the timetable, how
we are basically defining
the duties for vehicles
from the time that they pull
out from depot till the time
that they pull back
in to depot again.
What is the sequences of
the revenue trips or revenue
movements, and
where that involve
deadhead arcs, layover
arcs, and et cetera.
We will discuss
this in this lecture
and we will get to that.
So the task of
developing the timetable
is basically the task of
translating frequencies
into a timetable.
We may all be familiar with what
a bus service or train service
timetable is.
It basically includes the list
of departures and arrivals
to different stops
by different routes.
There are alternative ways
of determining the timetable.
The simplest way is to
just use equal head ways.
And the frequency that you
allocated to the route the time
period, during the
time period, just
distribute them evenly
over the time period.
If you look at the figure
on the bottom left here,
we will have an example
of even head ways here.
However, if the demand is not
uniformly distributed during
the period, for which the
example could be peak of peak,
that is usually happening--
depending on the network,
it may vary--
but usually happens between
7:00 and 8:00, 7:30 and 8:30.
Then we want to work
out the head ways,
and work out the
timetable in a way
to result in balanced
loads and equal loads.
So in order to do this,
what you need to do
is to generate the cumulative
passenger flow arrivals.
And then if you distribute
your headways on the time axis,
you will get even headways
or equal headway service.
If you distribute
your head weighs
on the cumulative
passenger flow evenly,
then you would get
balanced loads.
As you can see, the
headways which is here,
one, two, three, four,
five balancing loads
for time table development.
The other alternative way
of developing timetables
would be trying to design a
weight clock-face service.
Why would we want to design
a clock-face time table?
Does anyone have
any suggestions?
Yep.
AUDIENCE: Sometimes it
makes scheduling easier
if we have some sort
of cyclical pattern.
It's easier to assign
drivers that way.
PROFESSOR: Right, yes.
So that is actually one
reason-- it may eventually,
in the next step, which
is crew scheduling,
makes the service more
efficient and cost efficient.
Is there any other-- yep.
AUDIENCE: It's easier
for the passengers
to remember the schedule.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
If the waiting time
estimations that we are doing,
with respect to frequencies
and with respect to headways,
if passengers are able to
coordinate with the service,
the expected waiting time would
be less than the situation
where they cannot
coordinate with the service.
That's only the case when
headway is 10, 15, 20, 30
or minutes or 60 minutes.
And then we would
have service every--
on minute one, for
example, that that
would be 7-1, 7-11, 7-21,
and so on and so forth.
So it's easier for passengers
to remember the service that
is designed clock face.
So again, for the two approaches
to headway distribution,
equal heavy distribution
is basically,
as it can be
imagined, each headway
would be calculated as peak
period duration divided
by number of
vehicles or frequency
that we determined for the
route at the time period.
And in terms of
balance load solution,
we basically need to first
realize what the loads are,
the balance loads
are, by dividing
the passenger flows to
n and then work out,
on the cumulative
passenger arrivals,
to realize what the timetable
arrivals and departures are.
Is there any
questions about this?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Looking at the
graph on the left,
let's say PE4 minus
PE [INAUDIBLE]
is greater than the capacity of
a bus, then we have a problem.
Because if the number of
passengers there is [INAUDIBLE]
problem with the clock faced--
PROFESSOR: Mhm.
Yeah, that's-- however, what we
basically did in previous step,
in frequency determination,
that's one of the checks that
we do, the maximum load.
And we basically make
sure that maximum load is
within the allowed standards.
AUDIENCE: But
basically, so what we're
saying is if we do
clock faced, then
we look where we have the
maximum flow of passengers
and take that headway and
replicate that headway all
across the rest of
the time period,
is what you're saying if
I understand correctly.
I'm saying I have to design a
headway to serve the maximum,
and then the rest of the time
period, which has lower flows,
will have, you know,
excess capacity.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Yeah.
So yeah, that makes sense.
It really depends if we design
based on the time period
and we distribute the
frequencies evenly
and make sure that we are
checking the requirements that
are related to
maximum load factors,
then we won't have any problems.
However, the other issue
that could actually
be the counterpart of the
issue that you suggested
is that when we're designing the
timetable based on balance load
solution, we may
actually end up having
to use more vehicles
required for that solution.
And the reason for that--
does anyone have any suggestions
for the reason for [INAUDIBLE]
if the number--
why the number of
vehicles that we
may want to require
for balance [INAUDIBLE]
could be [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: Because if you have
a peak right at a certain time,
the vehicle would be
able to make one trip,
and then you'll be sending out
a bus just to make a single trip
and go back, which adds a lot
of deadhead time on either end.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Yeah.
So that could be one reason.
The other reason
would be if we have
a peak of peak in our
passenger arrivals,
then we would have really short
time intervals or short head
ways during peak of the peak,
and rather longer headways
during the off peak.
And then what happens is that
if these longer headways exceed
the maximum headway
that is allowed, then
we would have to basically throw
in more vehicles to make sure
that we do not exceed the
maximum headway allowed,
which is one of the
considerations related
to maximum waiting time
for passengers and level
of service.
So that's one of the issues.
So as a result, in
general, it is better
to assume that
design of timetable
is going to be based
on equal headways,
and when we do the
frequency computations,
be consistent with that.
AUDIENCE: So when we [INAUDIBLE]
and they are, like, strictly
bound to follow the movement
they are set on [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: I'm not sure I
understand your comment.
Can you repeat that please?
AUDIENCE: If
there's [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] then
the number of vehicles
is going to go up.
But since the number of vehicles
required during off-peak
[INAUDIBLE] then it
necessarily [INAUDIBLE]
you need more vehicles
during service [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: That's interesting.
I have a question--
why do you think
that a balance load
will require more vehicles?
I tend to believe
that it's somewhat
more efficient, capacity
wise, than the alternative.
Why do you think that
it has more vehicles?
AUDIENCE: I thought it was
because the frequency is
higher.
AUDIENCE: Only at
certain points.
It's higher only--
AUDIENCE: You have enough
vehicles to cover [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: But what
you were saying
is that you can't cut
service so short that you
don't need those load factors.
So in the end, you end
up using more vehicles.
PROFESSOR: So the reason
that we would basically
require more vehicles,
in balanced load,
is that for some
of these headways,
we need to stretch
the headway in a way
that it basically
meets the balance
load on the other headways.
And then, once we do that,
we may actually go over
the maximum allowed
headway, that
is basically trying to take
care of maximum waiting
time and level of
service in the end.
In that case, then we need
to throw in more vehicles
during the same
period of the route.
And if we need to do
this for all the routes
at the same time, then
we would eventually
observe more deficit, and
more vehicles to be used.
Is this the point
that you tried to--
AUDIENCE: Yes, but [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: On reverse?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, these
are two different factors
and both are important in
terms of level of service.
Headway consideration is
related to maximum waiting time.
You don't want to have like
reading the long headways that
would force people
to wait longer.
And at the same
time, you don't want
buses that are
overcrowded, and there's
discomfort resulting
from the crowding effect.
So these are two different
sources of this utility,
basically, in the service,
that we try to balance somehow.
The other issue that you brought
up first, in terms of the fact
that the service may be
directional, and demand
may be directional
during peak, and there
could be possibility of using
vehicles in other directions,
or using deadheading,
and situations
like that, we are actually
going to cover that.
And that's true for both
of the two scenarios.
AUDIENCE: It seems
like there should
be some kind of
hybrid way to say,
this is the amount of
vehicles I want to use--
and there's a way to not
have to go over schedule
based on equal headways, and
still [INAUDIBLE] demand.
PROFESSOR: Exactly, yeah.
And so there is all sorts of
tricks in these steps, where
you tweak some of the
solutions from one level
and go back to the previous
levels, and adjust those.
There is all sorts of
engineering judgments,
and the planning judgments that
are involved, and can actually
take place.
We will see a couple of
those in this lecture, too.
OK, so let's go.
So now, once we know
what the timetable is,
the sequence of arrivals and
departures for different trips,
for all routes,
then it's a matter
of determining what's
the fleet size that
is required for delivering the
service that is timetabled.
There is this famous
theorem in the literature
that deals with an
estimation of number of fleet
that is required.
It is basically an upper
bound to the number
of vehicles that are required
to deliver the service.
The reason that
it's an upper bound
is that it basically
assumes that we
are going to stick to
the original timetable,
and we are not allowed
to do any trip shifting,
or we are not doing any
trip shifting in this step
to accommodate some
of [INAUDIBLE] that
are one or two minutes, or a few
minutes basically conflicting.
And then the other
assumption that
is made here to compute the
upper bound of fleet size
is that we are not
allowing deadheading trips
to balance the deficit
among the terminals.
So let's start with
the definitions.
The function l of k, t, and
s-- k is the index of terminal,
t is the index of time, and s is
the index of the schedule that
is already developed.
So l is basically
the cumulative number
of departures from terminal by
time t following the schedule.
And a would be the
cumulative number
of arrivals at terminal k by
time t following that schedule.
Then we define a
function, which is
the difference
between the two, it's
basically the deficit
function which
is the cumulative departures
minus cumulative arrivals.
We use this deficit
function to estimate
what's the required to
deliver the service.
So the fleet size theorem
says that, if we basically
compute the maximum
number of deficit
over all time intervals for each
terminal, and we add those up,
we will get the total
number that is required--
number of vehicles
that is required
to deliver the service.
So it's basically this equation.
The summation over
all terminals, maximum
over t of the deficit function.
So in this figure,
we basically on top,
we see different trips
that are scheduled,
and each trip is basically
identified with a number
and a pair of terminals.
That's, for example, trip one,
it starts from terminal m,
and ends at terminal u.
And then, as you can see, these
trips all start at terminal m,
some of them go to u,
some of them go to v,
and there is also
trips between u and v,
and basically some of
them come back to m again.
So if we basically work
out the deficit function
for terminal m, what we
see is that, for example,
at time around 5:00 AM, we will
have one trip scheduled here,
trip number six.
And at 6:00, there
is another one.
Our deficit is basically
growing, until at noon,
where the first trip
comes back to terminal m.
And then, at that point, it
continues at a deficit level
three, where there is one
departure and one arrival
scheduled at 17, at 5:00 PM.
And then it continues until the
last trip arrivals, at a little
be before 10:00 PM.
So in this case, if we
look at the maximum deficit
over time for this
terminal, it would be four.
And that's for terminal m.
When we look at all
terminals in the network,
and some of the
maximum deficits,
the summation will give
us the number of fleet
that is required.
However, there are
a couple tricks
that we can basically
improve the efficiency.
One of the tricks
would be shifting
the departures or
arrivals a little,
bit so we accommodate
more trips.
If they're required,
for example,
in this case, like the deficit
part that actually gets
to level four, is as the result
of trip nine being scheduled
around like 11:15, or so.
If we can manage to shift
trip nine a little bit
forward, up to noon,
then we may actually
get rid of the fourth
unit of deficit
here, and make the total
deficit, or maximum deficit,
here equal to three.
There's also the
issue of reliability
that you may want to consider
for these trip arrivals
and departures.
For example, if you
look at this point
here, where trip two
arrives, and it's basically
based on this
method, it is going
to be assigned to trip eight.
However, what if trip two
is late by a few minutes?
What should be
doing in that case?
Are we going to delay trip
eight to accommodate that?
One way of looking at this is
that instead of working out
the deficit functions with trip
times, and then schedule trips,
we can work it out with half
cycles that already includes
layovers, and 95
percentiles at the terminus,
to make sure that we have
a leeway at the terminals.
That will definitely require
and result in higher deficits.
But again, if we are allowed
to shift the trips a little bit
back and forth, then
that's something
that would be recommended--
to work with half cycles,
instead of working with
the scheduled trips.
Is there any
questions about fleet
size required computation here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] to
reduce fleet size deficits?
Do they actually employ
the techniques of shifting?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, of course.
That's a part in timetable--
it's going back to one of the
steps that was already decided
and optimized in the past.
But there are all sorts of these
revisiting that is going on
in transit agencies.
Because we do not optimize
all the components
in an integrated manner,
all at the same time,
and we basically do a
sequential optimization,
there is always this
requirement to go back
to some of those
decisions that you thought
were optimal at the upper level,
and adjust those to account
for gains in the lower level.
AUDIENCE: I assume-- suppose
that this graph represents
an entire agency, and we'll
reduce that agency's fleet size
from four to three, saving
money on another bus.
That's a lot of
money in savings,
by not having that fourth bus.
Do they look--
PROFESSOR: When they
design timetables,
they try to have some
sort of coordination
with arrivals and
departures to the terminals.
There is an example at
the end of this lecture
that we're going to talk about,
how you can coordinate back
and forth trips, so it will
result in lower deficit
in the first place.
But yeah, sometimes
it may actually
be at the level of the
fleet size determination,
that you do this
these shiftings again
to improve the efficiency.
Any other questions?
It's a bit faster
on these parts.
So when it comes to matter of
vehicle scheduling problems,
it is a very interesting
problem to optimize.
The objective of this problem
is to define vehicle blocks,
or sequence of duties for
vehicles that includes revenue
trips and non-revenue trips.
In other words, deadheads
to rebalance, or to balance
the deficit at terminals.
Or layovers that would
actually take place
for reliability considerations.
So the objective is basically
to define these vehicle blocks,
given that we are going to cover
all the trips that are already
scheduled, in a way
to minimize the fleet
size as a measure
of the capital cost,
and minimize the non-revenue
time and mileage.
As a measure of a
non-revenue time,
could actually
account for crew cost,
and mileage could account
for both crew cost and fuel
and basic operational costs.
One important observation is
that these are proxies for us.
Again, in the [INAUDIBLE]
step of the work when
we are doing the
scheduling for crew,
we will realize
some of the costs
actually depends on how these
vehicle blocks are defined.
And probably the important
components of cost
that is related to--
they're related to
crew duties are going
to be determined in data stage.
So these are only proxies
for cost, fleet size,
and non-revenue
time and mileages.
Input into the vehicles
scheduling problem
would be [INAUDIBLE] vehicle
revenue trips is the timetable
that we are to deliver.
Each is characterized by trip
stop time, and the end time
and point.
Then the other input would
be possible layover arcs
to account for reliability of
these trips, and delay trips.
And deadhead arcs connecting
depots to trip starting
points-- we call those pull-out
arcs from [? depots. ?]
And then pull-ins back
into depots from trip end
points to depots.
And then the deadhead, or
balancing deficit arcs--
these are basically
trips that bring vehicles
from terminals with
lower deficit than what
is scheduled to terminals
with higher deficit.
So what we try to do is
that, from these arcs,
we certainly need to choose
the optimal combination
of these arcs to
deliver the service,
and bring our vehicles out
from depot and the same number
back to people depot again,
after the day is over.
So another important
observation, or quick note,
here, is that there may be many
possible number of deadhead
and layover arcs.
It's actually from a
combinatorial nature.
However, the designer,
or the person
who tries to solve this problem,
needs to review these arcs,
and come up with feasible and
plausible arcs to start with.
And then, as I mentioned,
the layover arcs
are also important in terms
of making sure we will have
a certain level of reliability.
There are variations to
the problem that actually
can make the problem
more complicated,
but we are going to stick
to the simplest one,
and show how we can formulate
the problem, model it, and what
are the algorithms that
can solve it for us.
These variations,
basically, are related to--
one possible
variation is related
to vehicles servicing single
lines, or single routes,
or inter-lining between
different routes.
The other variation would
be related to possibility
of having multiple depots
in the network, big,
larger transit agencies
usually have multiple depots.
For example, for Boston,
I know a few of those.
I do not know what's the
exact number of depots
that exist in the network.
Alfred Street is one--
AUDIENCE: Albany, Southhampton,
two of them at Lynn,
Fellsway, North
Cambridge-- that's it.
PROFESSOR: That's, yeah, OK,
so it's almost close to 10--
eight, nine.
OK, so when it comes to
different depots, and having
multiple depots, there
will be more complexities
introduced to the problem.
Because you may want to make
sure that the exact number
of vehicles who depart at a
depot, come back to depot.
There are also
some considerations
related to the fuel
that the fleet is using.
You may have diesel buses,
you may have CNG buses.
If you have restriction in
terms of fueling facilities
in these depots, you may want
to return back the vehicles
to the particular
depots that are
consistent with
the fueling system.
Then, there are
different considerations
related to vehicle types,
related to parking spaces
at the depots, and
that actually makes
the problem more complicated.
But we can actually make
some simplifying assumptions
for now, and see how
the problem looks
like in the most basic form.
So this is the time space
network representation
of the vehicle
scheduling problem--
we are trying, in the
next three slides,
we are trying to build on
the time and space network
structure, to realize what
is the decision that we're
trying to make, and how we
can basically solve this.
So this is time
space representation
with x-axis being time of
day, and y-axis being space.
This is only one
dimensional space here,
but it could be two
dimensional space, too.
So in this case,
we have two routes
that are represented
here-- route one,
or n routes-- route
one to route n.
As you can see there are
trips from either direction
of these routes, that
are already timetabled,
and we have already committed
to deliver this service.
So the black arcs
here are revenue arcs
that are the arcs
that we committed,
and these have to be
delivered between the two
terminals of every route.
Then we have-- in this problem,
we have only one depot.
There are two nodes here that
are represented as depot,
but it's basically
the representation
of depot at the beginning of
the day when vehicles pull out,
and the representation at the
end of the day when vehicles
pull in, basically.
There are also
layover arcs, where
you connect all possible
alternatives that you may think
would be plausible for
connecting these trips to one
another.
So in this figure, we
only have a few of those--
probably the closest
one-- but you
can work out any possible
combination of bus arrival
to a terminal, being
connected to a different trip
from that terminal.
AUDIENCE: Would
you mind explaining
what the [INAUDIBLE]?
Maybe I'm missing something.
Like, for example,
when we start out
at the beginning of
the day, [INAUDIBLE]..
We have two lines emanating from
the very beginning of the day,
so is that two buses leaving
the depot at the same time?
Maybe slightly different time?
PROFESSOR: Right, so let me go
ahead and continue and finish
all the arcs in the network--
that may clarify the situation.
Because there are other
arcs in the network, too.
So there are arcs that are
pull-out arcs, from the depot
to start these trips, and arcs
that return the vehicles back
to the depot.
There's also arcs that are there
to account for possibilities
of deadheading trips, from
one route to another route.
AUDIENCE: So now we have those
two nodes going into route one,
so two buses going
into route one, right?
PROFESSOR: That's only a link.
That link may include
multiple vehicles.
AUDIENCE: Multiple vehicles
at different times?
PROFESSOR: Multiple vehicles
at different times--
well, it could be--
yeah, this is not the
exact representation
of time-dependent service.
You can actually
have connections,
if you consider each
one of these links
to carry only one
vehicle or not,
then you need to add
vehicles from depot
to other trips along
the time dimension,
to vehicles that are
basically joining that route
[INAUDIBLE] time.
AUDIENCE: What is
the top [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: The top
line, you can--
the top line is just--
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It could be--
yeah, this is--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: This is, again,
a simplified situation,
but you can pull out at the
middle of the route, too.
Where you can, for example,
just serve a vehicle from here.
But you may want to make sure
that the scheduled trip is
served.
So if you have services
that's basically
a start from the middle of the
line, then you can model that,
too.
This is just to show how you
can model a situation like this.
It may not be all comprehensive
combinations, or situation.
AUDIENCE: I just wanted to make
sure I understand what it says.
PROFESSOR: Doesn't
id make sense now?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think so.
I think one of the confusing
things about this model,
actually, is that you
have that horizontal line.
And it's saying
[INAUDIBLE] revenue.
Really what you should have
is that layover arc shouldn't
be an arc, it should just be
a line connecting the end of--
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Exactly--
these horizontal lines,
I should actually remove that.
I will--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, just make
the layover arcs lines.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
exactly, layover arcs--
that's exactly true.
Actually, make the connection
between the two directions
of the route, and then the
other arcs that are involved
are the deadhead arc's
points in the network.
AUDIENCE: But it could
be noted that the layover
arcs are not really--
[INAUDIBLE] there's no
spatial dimension to them,
because the bus isn't moving.
PROFESSOR: Right, yeah, exactly.
Maybe that's-- the only spatial
dimension to it would be just
go ahead and turn
around over the corner.
And then come back, yeah.
AUDIENCE: It would
still be the case
that the bus that pulls into the
terminal is the next one out.
So that's when you might
actually want to have the arc,
to show that even though
it's not really moving--
[INAUDIBLE] there
is a reason why you
might want to show it that way.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
And then the other
point is that, this
is, like even front from this
node to nodes further down,
the reason that we
are [INAUDIBLE] think
the optimization problem
in the network structure,
like many other
optimization problems,
is that with networks that
consists of nodes and arcs,
we can represent the
constraints very efficiently.
And there are
efficient algorithms
that use this representation to
solve the optimization problem.
So whenever we can present
an optimization problem
in a network
structure, we do that,
because we have really
elegant algorithms and network
flows that can be used to
solve optimization problems.
So let's see what's the
optimization problem we
are trying to solve here.
One other link that
we need to add here
is basically from
depot to depot,
to make sure that the total
number of vehicles that
are going out of the
depot, in the morning,
are going to be equal to
the total number of vehicles
that are coming back to depot.
AUDIENCE: So we're
assuming-- just
to go back to that--
there are some lines there
that don't have a pull-out,
so we assume those
are coming from other depots?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
in this example,
we are only simplifying it
into one depot situation,
but some of the--
yeah, exactly--
some of the other routes
could actually be--
AUDIENCE: I guess the
question is, if a route ends,
the first one that's going
from the bottom to the top
doesn't have a
pull-out, and so there
should be an arrow going back.
PROFESSOR: There should be
an arrow, yeah, to that, too.
But it's missing in this.
These arrows are
only representative,
and they are not comprehensive.
And we basically are
defining integer capacities
that would reflect
a number of vehicles
that are doing that
duty, or are basically
assigned to those duties.
These arcs are revenue,
layover, and deadhead arcs.
And these arcs,
again, have costs.
Like revenue arcs have
given amount of cost,
depending on the time that they
take to make the trip, and so
on and so forth.
Layover trips, depending
on how much time they take.
And deadhead arcs, depending
on how much time they take,
and how much mileage
they require to travel,
the vehicles.
However, what's interesting
is that [INAUDIBLE]
arcs costs of zero for those,
because it's not relevant.
We eventually would have to
deliver those revenue arc
services.
So it's a constant in
the optimization problem.
We might as well
just remove them.
But what's important
is that when we
want to see what the layovers--
what's the optimal combination
of layovers and deadheads
in this problem?
So again, the bounds that
we have for revenue arcs
is basically lower bound
is one, upper bound is one.
Why is it like this?
Does anyone have
any suggestion, why
the lower bound and upper
bound are both equal to one
for revenue arcs?
AUDIENCE: Because you
said we have to operate
the trips, no matter what.
PROFESSOR: And we only have to
operate to deliver them once,
right?
Remember, these are trips in
the time space representation.
So each trip is
basically one arc--
we need to deliver it once.
So it's basically the matter
of choosing [INAUDIBLE]
or configuration of layover
arcs between zero and one,
and deadhead arcs
between zero and one.
A maximum block length
is a guarantee--
this is usually not a problem.
If the fuel
situation, especially
for electric vehicles,
is restricting,
we may want to put additional
restrictions on maximum length
of the vehicle.
But with the existing
diesel and CNG vehicles,
these are usually fine to
deliver the whole service day
services without
having to refuel.
It's [INAUDIBLE]
that is something
that is already taken care of in
the vehicle scheduling problem.
However, shifting
heuristic needs
to take place before we
get to vehicle scheduling,
at the level of
timetable development,
as we discussed after
the deficit functions.
So the matter would be the--
if we have multiple
depot, the problem
becomes a little bit
more complicated.
For single depot situation,
we solved the problem
with network flow algorithms,
minimum cost flow algorithm,
that is very efficient
and very, very fast.
When it comes to [INAUDIBLE]
flow with integer, [INAUDIBLE]
which is [INAUDIBLE] in
the problem that we have,
that problem becomes really
difficult. It becomes NP-hard,
and it basically is
very difficult to scale.
That basically
means that we do not
use the network flow algorithms
for multi depot situation.
We use some of the existing
[INAUDIBLE] stakes.
Are there are any questions
about this so far?
So this is another
network representation
of the multiple vehicle
scheduling problem.
This is not a time space
representation anymore,
because it would become really
complicated with time space
representation.
As you can see, there
are different depots
in the network, and there
are different services
that need to actually--
or revenue arcs--
that need to be served.
There may be some
constraints on number
of vehicles that pull out
from each one of these depots,
and the pull in each
one of these depots.
And again, if we didn't
have the constraint
of having integer solution, this
could be solved in linear time,
too.
However, with integer
constraints, it's not possible.
So is there any
questions about this?
It basically-- in order to
be able to implement this,
we need to make a
definition on trips,
and identify compatible trips.
Two compatible trips at a
terminal, I and J, two trips I
and J are compatible
at the terminal,
if J is arriving to terminal,
I is departing from terminal,
and the time difference
between the two
is actually greater than
the layover that we want.
And then, also, less than twice
the time of traveling to depot.
The solution may be only as
good as just sending the vehicle
back to depot, and then
pull it out from depot
to another part of the network.
So we only restrict the
search for compatible trips
to these two bounds.
Like MK here is the
minimum recovery time
that we define as a
lower bound of time
difference between the arrival
of trip I minus departure
of trip J. And
then, we use 2 times
DK, which is the deadhead
time from terminal to depot.
Then the algorithm
is really simple--
it has only four steps.
We start with the earliest
arrival at terminal.
If there is no earliest
arrival, we go to step D.
And basically, in step D, we
need to pull out from depot
to serve that service.
But if there is one
earliest arrival,
then we link that
earliest arrival
to compatible trip departure,
based on the compatibility
constraint, or
definition that we had.
Again, if there is no trips
that is compatible with that,
we need to go back to
step A, and basically use
the next arrival at terminal.
If there is one trip that is
compatible with the trip that
arrives, then we will
check the vehicle block
length against the
existing constraint.
Again, that could actually
be related to the fuel,
fueling constraint,
and so on and so forth.
If it's constraining,
then we need
to do to cancel that and
return the vehicle to depot.
Otherwise, we would
basically make the connection
between the compatible
trips, and consider
the second trip a new arrival
to the other [? extreme ?]
[INAUDIBLE] basically.
After that, we serve, again,
all remaining unlinked trips
from depot.
We need to work out in
your mind these steps once.
It's very easy to practice,
to realize how this works.
But it's basically using
the strict first in,
first out rule, based on
compatibility of trips
and over the compatible trips.
Is there any question?
AUDIENCE: Kind of going back
a little bit, [INAUDIBLE]
the single depot [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: For single
depot situation,
the existing algorithms
that solve minimum cost
flow, like successive shortest
path algorithm, or some
of the negative cycle
canceling algorithms,
can give you integer solution.
However, when it
comes to multi-depot,
and when it comes to
multi-commodity flow,
that's not always true.
So you may actually get a
solution with a linear--
or with a network flow algorithm
that is in linear time,
but it's not integer.
So you may have you decimal,
or partial vehicles going back
to different depots.
That's the difference
between the two cases.
So other questions?
All right, so after this, we
will have just one single route
of scheduling practice,
with two nodes, A and B,
or with two terminals,
A and B. This
is one route that we want to
schedule for AM peak period,
and base period.
AM peak is defined
from 6:00 to 9:00.
And base period is after 9:00.
Headways are during
peak period, 20 minutes.
And scheduled trip times are
40 minutes for both directions.
Layover is 10.
During off-peak,
headways are 30.
Scheduled trip time is 35.
And minimum layover
is, again, 10.
Dominant direction
of travel is AM peak.
And it's in the
direction of A to B.
So then, what we do is that we
will [INAUDIBLE] direction A
to B, and given the
headways and running times,
we work out the [INAUDIBLE]
for all the trips
that are scheduled during
peak from 6:00 to 9:00,
and then after that up
to 11:00, and the rest
could be actually similar.
So as you can see, the
headways from 6:00 to 9:00
are 20 minutes, after that
it becomes 30 minutes.
The running time is 40
minutes in the peak, and 35
[INAUDIBLE].
First thing that we do is
that we tie the two directions
together.
This is the kind of
coordination that we previously
discussed with the comment
that [? Aton ?] made
in terms of shifting
these trips together.
So this is one example of
shifting some of the trips
to make better efficiency
in the next steps.
In this case, we tie the
trips in the first direction
with trips in the
reverse direction.
So first trip that departs
at 6:00 arrives at 6:40.
Considering 10
minutes layover, we
will schedule the first trip
for the reverse direction
from 6:50.
And it's anticipated
to arrive at 7:30.
And this is so on and so
forth for all the timetable,
given the travel times between
the two ends, and the headways.
AUDIENCE: Which means
we need five buses?
PROFESSOR: Yes, but
you will work this out.
Right, we need five buses, but
some of them are partial only.
They can pull in in the
middle, and pull out.
But we will see
that in a second.
So we will start
with first pull-out--
that is the bus that is going
to serve the first round trip.
After one cycle,
it's going to be
able to serve the
7:40 trip for us,
after 10 minutes of layover.
It will end this trip at 9:10.
Given 10 minutes
layover, it will
be able to serve 9:30 for
us, and also 11:00 again.
The next bus that we
will have to pull out
can serve the trip from
6:20, and from 8:00.
After 8:00, once it does the
cycle, it's going to be 9:30.
And 9:30 is already--
trip is already taken.
Then we will have to
choose between sending
this back to the depot, or
using it for trip at 10:00.
This trip at 10:00 basically
means like 30 more minutes,
or 20 minutes of
waiting, we decide
to send it back to depot.
We will have five blocks
for five different buses.
Block one basically
gives the itinerary
of duties for bus
one, or for whichever
bus that this is assigned to.
Then so on and so forth
for all the buses.
You mainly will have to
work with this method
for the homework.
But it's valuable to know
what are the [INAUDIBLE]
approaches in
practice, and what's
going on in research that
deals with problems like this.
Any questions?
All right, OK.
Thank you very much.